viel geflucht bilder werden auch in der
deutschen bahn viel geflucht sich nicht
mehr in der deutsch- man aber über die
deutsche bahn über die habe ich mich
heute aufgeregt denn sie war heute als
ich mit der bahn hin gekommen wenn mal
wieder zu spät immerhin ist sie gefahren
ist nicht ausgefahren wie wiedersehen
aber es war nur 40 minuten mehr aber es
waren 40 minuten mehr als die züge in
der schweiz in österreich in südkorea in
china und sonstwo auf der welt kommen
wenn sie normalerweise kommen denn sie
sind dort immer pünktlich und wir
fehlanzeige und gerade das in einem jahr
in dem wir mehr bahn fahren sollen
weniger fliegen weniger auto fahren das
klima wegen es wäre es kann denn eine
voll
funktionsfähige bahn die zudem auch
pünktlich ist ist immer mehr nur die
ausnahme und nicht werden seltsam ist
nur jede woche hört man irgendwelche
neuen tollen botschaften wir haben ein
super fahrplan der neue super verbindung
wir haben neue ec ski fahren länger und
breiter und was weiß ich alles als es
vorher je gegeben hat nur es kommt
leider nichts irgendwo an schon gar
nicht auf der schiene mittlerweile
planen ist ja immer so ein puffer eins
und zwei stunden oder so war ich denke
irgendwie muss ja ankommen und
rechtzeitig da sein und ich kenne viele
viele und lese auch von vielen diensten
so gut was mich aber umso mehr stört ist
die teilnahmslosigkeit der menschen auch
in der bahn kuppelshow heute noch eine
netflix folge auch egal so kommen zu
spät fährt länger langsamer es sind ja
auch nicht nur die züge selbst die klos
in caputh die restaurants die bistros
sind leer oder auch funktionsunfähig die
klimaanlage funktioniert nicht die
heizung nicht wackelt und rappelt
überall und das sind nur ein paar der
probleme aber sagen wir was dazu regen
wir uns darüber aus nein denn dieses
land ist irgendwie in den letzten zwölf
jahren der groko in eine komplette
teilnahmslosigkeit com bekommt
teilnahmslosigkeit dass missstände
angeht weil die menschen sind
gleichgültig nach dem motto irgendwann
müssten wir ja was dran ändern aber wir
glauben nicht mehr dass das überhaupt
passiert während herum eben alle alles
ändern und die anderen nationen wirklich
zuhauf an uns vorbeiziehen ich finde das
darf nicht sein denn diese einstellung
geht unser land vor die hunde wir haben
jetzt ein interregnum da passiert
sowieso auch nichts sich die nächste
jung gebildet hat ich finde wir sollten
wie fahrpläne gänzlich abschaffen nur
noch den fuß meldung aufsehen die zucht
kommt heute dann und dann weil der
fahrplan der stimmt ja sowieso nicht
also es machen wie es im richtigen leben
ist ich würde den ball gern aufnehmen
weil ich darin natürlich ein ähnliches
grundproblem sehe dass ich bei
digitalisierung auch gesagt haben wir
haben wir sind irgendwie wir haben das
akzeptiert und vom anspruchsdenken her
ist es vollständig richtig glaube es war
in tokio im fall dafür die bahn 20 95
sekunden zu früh aus dem bahnhof und
dann mussten die sich öffentlich
entschuldigen weil der fahrgast in allen
zügen im musste und sechs minuten
verspätung hat also sechs minuten zählt
bei uns in der messung noch als
pünktlich
und das noch als vertreter für den
ländlichen raum das muss ich auch noch
anhängen also ich muss hier an reisen
mit der bahn ist es wenn es gut läuft
sechseinhalb bis sieben stunden also an
der stelle sind wir nicht
konkurrenzfähig
jetzt natürlich wisse nicht wie eine
rolle hier nur zu meckern deswegen wird
es keinen wundern dass als liberaler
genäht ich glaube dass mehr wettbewerb
an der stelle helfen kann deswegen hin
zum beispiel aus meiner sicht mit china
zum ein gesellschaftlicher beispiele
sind da schwierig zum anderen glaube ich
nicht dass da noch mehr privatisierung
hälfte an der stelle also wir brauchen
da eigentlich mehr wettbewerb auf der
schiene da ich hier dahin gar nicht weil
china war vor 20 jahren völlig ihn
dauert es gibt nicht so viele
einspruchsmöglichkeit für neue trassen
und dergleichen stimmt da braucht man
also durch aber japan ist es auch schon
mit und pünktlich und so südkorea
genauso also das ist kein
hinderungsgrund auf die menschenrechte
in china zu kommen also zunächst mal
entschuldigen dass ich wieder ins wort
gefallen bin weil ein vortrag ist mir so
durchgerutscht werde ich beim nächsten
mal doppelt bei dir macht das prinzip
ich habe die erwartung gestalten wir
jetzt zustimmen ich bin natürlich
zweimal mit angeblichen ics gefahren die
beide keine waren und der zweite war der
interessanteste er hat eine rote
diesellok vorne dran zu mir ich lese
auch und weißbrot ja die swing rotwein
und hinten waren wagen angehängt die
habe ich schon mal vor jahrzehnten
gesehenes formal zwischen
dortmund und
1970 was wählt er ist glaube ich
metropolis der metropol oder metronom
der zug das war so ein luxuszug da muss
man extra für bezahlen da waren drinnen
die sitze aus leder und alles holz
getäfelt und ich habe das grob
wiedererkannt als ob vorne die schäbige
lockt hinten uralte waggons aber
interessante der ist natürlich stunden
später angekommen als er sollte oder hat
es aber nie preis bezahlt ja das ist so
deutsche bahn und ich glaube du hast ihn
am ende das genau richtige ist in diesem
land jetzt rüber ich sehr stark
funktioniert nichts mehr jedenfalls
nichts was der staat machen soll und in
berlin schon mal gar nicht also was man
von der neuen regierung erwarten muss
ich sage nicht kann erwarten muss ist
dass er das erkennt und daran arbeitet
und wenn sie von modernisierung und von
fortschritt spricht als das zunächst mal
aufholen des rückstands den wir haben in
allen möglichen bereichen ja und hier
meist die erklärung der für paul ist ja
wenn die störung im betriebsablauf wenn
so etwas passiert ist wir haben nun mal
wegen störungen im betriebsablauf kommen
wir nicht an für die bahn ja wie die lok
nicht was heißt denn das begehrte wagen
vor allen dingen im vorstand der
deutschen bahn scheint eine störung zu
sein weil ja die leute die da arbeiten
ich weiß nicht ich denke immer noch
hatten und mehdorn ist das wichtigste
aber ist er nicht aber
er hat notfall hat aber was soll also
sollte man den wieder rausholen naja
oder handschriften doch jetzt einige zu
versorgen in der jetzigen
bundesregierung hat mit verwirrten dann
da
versorgungsmentalität macht sich eben
lässt sich wieder einen staat machen
noch lässt sich eine basis haben wir
viel zu viel ja also ich bei dir denn
als bahnchef wer wird es schaffen dass
es da besser euch wann tatsächlich meter
und hat damals einen guten job gemacht
er ist jetzt ein bisschen halt dafür
dann wird es nicht tun ich würde mir ein
manager wie wir haben reitzle wünschen
oder jemand der wirklich gezeigt hat
dass sie krisen unternehmen warum wenden
kann uns wenden kann und jemand der
anpackt und tatsächlich wenig rücksicht
nehmen muss auf politischen
befindlichkeiten daran krankt es ja auch
reitzel ist ein sehr guter vorschlag in
der hand sicher
bin wirst du dir wünschen ich würde mir
einen wünschen der ist aber niemals
machen wird weil er aus dem consumer
goods kommt und zweitens kasper rorstedt
legendär bei henkel gewesen jetzt
legendär war die das gewesen dass wenn
man vor allem auch als denen natürlich
überhaupt nicht in den politischen
zirkus irgendwo verankert kasper
rorstedt werde ich mein favourit würde
aber niemals machen ich glaube der markt
seine consumer goods ganz gerne und so
stehen also noch so ist der beste den
man krieg könnte ich teile schon dass
der externer wind durchaus charme hat
weil ich meine die bahn ist ein an der
stelle wirklich in unserer jungs fall
was man aufholen muss im management in
den prozessen und so das ist jemand der
nicht verhaftet ist ihnen aber auch das
müsste doch eigentlich sollten ein
wichtiges thema jetzt sein oder für
gerade für die grünen und für die fdp
technologie land deutschland und so
weiter klimaschutz was was kann man sich
davor stellen es immer noch relevant das
sprechzimmer weil der punkt der in einem
halbsatz kam aufholen ja aber wir sind
wir sprechen immer nur oder oft
politisch zumindest früher über aufholen
das kann und darf aber auch nicht der
anspruch von einer ampel sein es geht ja
auch darum wie geht so leider hat er das
war schwere form der pitch nach
multimodalität also das quasi ich über
verschiedene medien bis hin eigentlich
zur autonomen zu bringen was im
ländlichen raum natürlich mehr sinn
macht wie ein bus der einfach da seine
kreise fährt weil einer gesagt hat macht
also das sind halt alles was du über
bleibst du die nicht gehen deswegen ist
es natürlich ein extrem relevant des
themas ist nur größer wie bahn weil es
mobilität ist was aber nicht heißt dass
die bahn als trage achse des ganzen wenn
wir das klimaneutral hinbekommen
wesentlich konkurrenzfähiger werden muss
weil sie wie gesagt für mich macht es
dann eben aus anstand weil ich irgendwie
versucht den planet zu retten aber
sieben stunden ist halt kein attraktives
beförderungs angebot da müssen wir uns
halt auch ehrlich wir kriegen schon
einen digitalisierungs ministerium auch
das weiß ich nicht ich würde einmal
richtig sehen minuten erstellen
gerade
im unterton da werden sie
parlamentarischer staatssekretär
das ist nett oder
so statt sich dann auch gott august
wagen gibt es auch ein schönes büro also
beteilige mich auch nicht an mir aber
ich habe ja die ganze formation mitten
und hier im hinterzimmer hinaus ist oder
so irgendetwas schneider ja die kommen
bei mir so 21 uhr 16
dann machen wir ein bisschen länger und
setzte dann auf ein händler die
abschläge
wie ist denn die vielleicht jemand
begegnet bei sap noch einer der wo du
sagst er könnte es machen ihnen
also ich bin ja auch alles brauchen
erfahrene manager wobei ich ehrlich
gesagt auch dann offen sagen muss dass
in so größeren gebilden dann durchaus
auch startup charakter fehlt also den
wir kriegen kein narr wer stellt denn
der spieler sowieso nicht weil ich schon
glaube man muss sich das als teenager
oben jemand mit strahlkraft da gab es
gar gab es wirklich namen aber dann
ununterbrochen ich herzlicher daten
[Musik]